Hôm nay đúng đăng trên Trúc Sto Show rằng,
của các của ông với tổng thống Ngà Vladimir Putin sẽ tiến ra và ngày 30 tháng tấm tới tại thử băng
Alaskar của Haki.
Hôm nay, thử mình mấy ngày được đánh sá là giữa kẹn đối ngoại đáng chú ý.
Bởi tới là lần đầu tiên tổng thống đúng đăng trăm và tổng thống Vladimir Putin
đập trực tiếp kể từ năm 2020,
biểu lợi trọng Alaskar, phị trị địa lý gần nha,
được qua là thung địa mang tính biểu tượng,
thị hiện thiện chi tu hệ khổn cách cả về không 3 lẫn chiến chi.
Trước thêm cuộc gặp 2倍 là có những tiện hiệu hạn như thăng hàng,
dù các bất đồng, các biệt là liên quan tự quen nhà vẫn chưa có lời dài sống sàng,
rồi qua xin nhìn định hộ nghĩ này sẽ không chỉ bàn về hòa biện hiệu quen nhà,
mà còn đặt liên mỏng trước sự điều trình quán hiện nghỉn hai trong sạy hạn.
Dù kì vào cao, kìa qua thình chắc vẫn phụ thuộc vào mức độ nhiều bộ của một lên và cách hỏi các bằng lợi chính là.